one of the things that that you do that  I that I really love I think a lot of  people like this gestures that you put  your son Assad right Assad on your album  covers here's one of them and he's just  hanging out we should point out for  safety reasons he's he's not alone there  yeah I was underwater holding him up you  say that cover again he cuz you're  drowning while this is happening yeah  it's not Photoshop and I was like  manages it I want him like Scarface  you were saying but Assad in the jacuzzi  so I went underwater and it's held him  up yeah but he knew what to do and put  his hands  you know like father like son yeah hey  me what to do he look at this guy that's  right you know I said young Carly young  to Assad Assad he knows that dove deal  is coming through  you